[Música]
al menos 13 personas murieron y otras 50
resultaron heridas dos misiles rusos que
estallaron contra un centro comercial el
hecho ocurrió en la ciudad de kremenchug
en el centro de ucrania tenemos reportes
desde este país
las naciones del g7 condenaron el ataque
en el centro comercial ucraniano y
reiteraron que respaldarán aquí en el
tiempo que sea necesario el presidente
del univers el skip habló con los
líderes de los siete países en el
segundo día de la ruta
ser y la ncaa limita el combustible y
sólo lo permitirá para servicios
esenciales como la salud o el transporte
público también cerrará las escuelas las
medidas intentan hacerle frente a la
grave escasez que enfrenta el país y que
ha disparado las manifestaciones desde
mayo
bienvenidos a las noticias
internacionales de france 24 mi nombre
es maría jara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos comenzamos en ucrania donde
varios puntos civiles fueron atacados
este lunes en lysychansk murieron al
menos 8 personas y otras 21 resultaron
heridas el gobierno local afirma que
ellas estaban recolectando agua en un
carro cisterna cuando llegaron los
misiles rusos más hacia el oeste en la
ciudad de crimen chuck un centro
comercial fue atacado con 2 rockets al
menos 13 civiles fallecieron y 50 están
heridos desde la ciudad de jarquín
nuestra enviada especial leticia álvarez
nos da más detalles de este ataque
se condena unánime internacional ataque
con misiles contra un centro comercial
en la región de poltava muy alejado de
objetivos militares el portavoz de la
secretaria general de naciones unidas lo
ha calificado de deplorable y el propio
primer ministro británico boris johnson
ha denunciado el barbarismo de vladimir
putin este ataque contra civiles se
produce en plena reunión del g7 donde
los líderes de las principales naciones
industrializadas en la unión europea han
mostrado su solidaridad con ucrania y su
intención de seguir apoyando a este país
el tiempo que haga falta portaban una
región alejada del frente que sirve de
centro para acoger a refugiados que
huyen de zonas mucho más complicadas
como la que nos encontramos en jarquín y
también es un centro para las sedes de
las organizaciones internacionales
mañana es un día feriado aquí en ucrania
es el día de la constitución y las
autoridades han pedido a los ciudadanos
que se alejen de las aglomeraciones de
los centros comerciales y que eviten
ponerse en peligro y hacer caso a las
alarmas porque la situación está
empeorando las fronteras están
desdibujando y rusa está ganando terreno
no son más también aquí en jarkiv el
número de ataques lo hemos podido
comprobar estas últimas noches sigue
aumentando en el este de ucrania
y precisamente ucrania fue el tema
central de la segunda de tres jornadas
de la cumbre del g7 que se realiza en
alemania los líderes de los siete países
conversaron telefónicamente con
volodymyr selenski el mandatario
ucraniano y prometieron que seguirán
respaldando aquí es tanto tiempo como
sea necesario
luís muñoz con los detalles
y promesas para ucrania el grupo de los
países más ricos del mundo el g7 en su
segunda jornada de cumbre en alemania
conversó por videoconferencia con
volodymyr selenski presidente ucraniano
en un comunicado los principales líderes
mundiales prometieron seguir ayudando a
combatir la invasión rusa
seguiremos brindando apoyo financiero
humanitario militar y diplomático y
apoyaremos a ucrania todo el tiempo que
sea necesario es la respuesta a las
peticiones que les hizo de lenski este
reveló en telegrama el contenido de la
conversación
ucrania siente el apoyo de los estados
del g7
gracias por su defensa y asistencia
financiera a nuestro país en la lucha
contra la invasión rusa para nosotros la
posición coherente de los países del g7
sobre las sanciones también es
importante deben seguir aumentando en
particular limitando el precio del
petróleo exportado del agresor
en otro mensaje excelente y concreto en
cinco puntos las peticiones seguridad
reanudación de exportaciones agrícolas
reconoce la rusia como patrocinador del
terrorismo
reconstrucción del país y más defensa
antimisiles a este último punto se
comprometió el asesor de seguridad
nacional de la casa blanca jake sullivan
por su parte el canciller alemán olaf
scholz anfitrión de la cumbre se mostró
satisfecho todas nuestras políticas
están alineadas este creo es un buen
mensaje estamos tomando decisiones
difíciles y esto es lo esencial para ser
duros y pensar en las necesidades del
tiempo que estamos viviendo
el g7 está formado por alemania eeuu
francia italia canadá japón y reino
unido-
en este 2022 ya han comprometido 29 mil
500 millones de dólares en apoyo a
ucrania nos vamos al sur de asia el
gobierno de sri lanka limitará el uso
del combustible hasta el 10 de julio y
solo lo permitirá para servicios
esenciales como la salud los trenes o
los vehículos que transporten alimentos
todo esto es para intentar apaciguar la
peor crisis económica en siete décadas
una grave escasez de combustible es la
expresión de la peor crisis económica de
sri lanka en siete décadas en un intento
desesperado para hacer frente a esta
situación las autoridades cerraron las
escuelas en colombo la capital pidieron
a los empleados públicos que trabajen
desde casa e informaron que sólo
suministran combustible a los servicios
esenciales como la sanidad los trenes y
los autobuses durante dos semanas a
partir del martes los ciudadanos hacen
largas colas para comprar gasolina
llevo aquí desde la medianoche del
viernes cuando llegamos habían dejado de
bombear gasolina no sé si tendré
gasolina o no de momento me han dado un
balín
entretanto una delegación de alto nivel
de los departamentos de tesoro y de
estado de eeuu se reunió con los
dirigentes de la isla para explorar las
formas de brindar ayuda mientras que un
equipo del fondo monetario internacional
llegó para mantener conversaciones sobre
un posible paquete de rescate de tres
mil millones de dólares el país asiático
ya había recibido cuatro mil millones de
dólares la financiera de su vecina india
y las autoridades han hecho un llamado a
la austeridad
calama nada carne inicia cargos y due
nature abré a mi ama vio tendremos que
enfrentarnos a varios retos a veces
podremos acabar con las colas de
gasolina por completo otras veces no
podremos acabar con las colas creo que
no podremos obtener 550 560 millones de
dólares en los próximos meses
definitivamente tendremos que reducir
nuestro consumo a 350 millones de
dólares
youtube la oposición y una gran mayoría
de ciudadanos exigen la dimisión del
presidente gotabaya rajapaksa su hermano
el ex primer ministro máquina rajapaksa
renunció en mayo por la misma razón la
familia es acusada de acaparar y dar mal
manejo a los negocios del estado
precipitando la crisis actual mientras
que la demanda de pasaportes se ha
disparado ya que muchos intentan huir
del país
comenzó la segunda conferencia de la onu
sobre los océanos en lisboa los
asistentes a la cumbre buscan un acuerdo
internacional sobre las aguas de alta
mar pero todavía no se vislumbra un
pacto andrés granadillo nos cuenta
una emergencia oceánica así es como
define el secretario general de la onu
antonio guterres el estado general de
los océanos en la segunda conferencia de
las naciones unidas sobre este tema
el calentamiento global está llevando la
temperatura de los ciudadanos a niveles
récord creando tormentas más feroces y
frecuentes el nivel del mar está
subiendo las naciones insulares de baja
altitud se enfrentan a inundaciones al
igual que muchas de las principales
ciudades costeras del mundo cities
indujo la onu afirma que los océanos se
enfrentan a una grave amenaza por el
calentamiento global la contaminación y
la acidificación por ello unas 7000
personas de 120 países entre jefes de
estado científicos y ong evaluarán los
avances en la aplicación de una
directiva para proteger la vida marina
la conferencia busca adoptar una
declaración que ayudaría a implementar y
facilitar la protección y conservación
de los océanos y sus recursos aunque
está aún fuera del alcance un acuerdo
internacional conocido como tratado de
alta mar que vaya más allá de la
jurisdicción nacional
activistas consternados por el fracaso
en políticas de protección protestaron
en las playas de lisboa
los océanos están vacíos estamos
capturando menos peces ahora que hace 30
años con todos los avances y tecnologías
necesitamos una acción adecuada que no
estamos viendo por parte de nuestros
líderes no se informara la ley 3 el
océano cubre alrededor del 70% de la
superficie del planeta genera el 50 por
ciento del oxígeno y absorbe el 25 por
ciento de las emisiones de dióxido de
carbono pero unos 8 millones de
toneladas de residuos plásticos llegan a
las aguas cada año y si no se toman
medidas en los polímeros podrían superar
a todos los peces de los océanos en 2050
además al absorber más del 90% del
exceso de calor provocado por el
calentamiento global se han generado
olas de calor marinas masivas que están
acabando con los preciosos arrecifes de
coral indispensables para la
supervivencia de las especies bajo el
agua hoy terminaron las audiencias por
los atentados en francia ocurridos el 13
de noviembre de 2015 y en los que
murieron 130 personas el próximo 29 de
junio será el veredicto final la
historia la tiene a erika olavarría dos
días después de iniciado el proceso el
pasado 8 de septiembre nancy esta
chilena que perdió a su hijo luis felipe
en la sala de conciertos bataclán
aterrizaba en parís
no tenía abogado tampoco se había
constituido en parte civil y ni siquiera
tenía unas vacunas reconocidas por
francia pero sabía que quería estar
presente
en estos meses nancy consiguió un
abogado que hable español pero también
se armó toda una vida en parís colao
nicolás este hotel que paga el estado
francés se ha convertido en su casa
esta gente me ha cogido súper bien bueno
tanto tiempo que permaneció acá pero han
sido para mí súper súper súper
acogedores y le expliqué el eje estoy en
el proceso por lo tanto
necesito permanecer en un lugar mucho
tiempo y bueno me preguntaron por qué
que siguió entonces ellos empecé a
explicar y ellos tienen estos estos
estos atentados muy en la retina
todos fueron muy afectados por esto
en el escritorio de la pequeña
habitación revistas y libros que hablan
de este proceso fuera de lo común son un
regalo de un policía su intérprete o la
madre de otra de las víctimas he tenido
mucha mucha información
respecto a cómo pasó en el bataclán como
entran al bataclán yo me imagino cómo
murió mi hijo
horrible cada día de forma religiosa a
nancy así está el proceso solo faltó en
febrero cuando regresó a chile para
conocer a su nieto pero también porque
necesitaba urgentemente hacer una pausa
en la recta final la chilena considera
que las penas que pidieron los fiscales
no son lo suficientemente severas yo
venía con nuestras expectativas que
estos tipos no salieran nunca más de la
cárcel que quiero porque todo para mí
todos son uno en mayor o menor medida
pero todos contribuyeron para que toda
esto pasara tras cada audiencia la carga
se alivia en parte gracias a la
conversación con otros familiares en el
patio de la corte nancy tiene ahora más
información que cuando llegó aunque hay
muchas dudas no han sido resueltas
pasamos a américa latina cuando se
cumplen 15 días de protestas en ecuador
los indígenas que han liderado las
marchas en contra del alza de los costos
de vida accedieron a dialogar con el
gobierno la reunión comenzó este lunes
pero el presidente guillermo lasso no
asistió el mandatario se dio a una de
las demandas de las protestas y rebajó
los precios de la gasolina y del diésel
aunque no tanto como se lo pedían
un nuevo intento por frenar las
protestas favoreciendo la baja del
combustible el presidente guillermo lazo
espera abordar una de las principales
demanda de los indígenas he decidido
reducir el precio de la gasolina extra y
eco país en 10 centavos por galón y el
diesel también en 10 centavos por galón
la medida se da luego que el lazo
levantar el estado de emergencia que
había impuesto en seis provincias y de
iniciar un diálogo con los líderes de
las protestas en ese país la producción
petrolera se encuentra en niveles
críticos y ha disminuido el 50 por
ciento de su producción dejando de
percibir alrededor de 120 millones de
dólares según el ministerio de energía
los precios de los combustibles ya
estaban congelados desde el año pasado
todos consideran que el precio de los
combustibles se ha convertido en la
piedra angular que mantiene el conflicto
y aunque como gobierno tenemos muy claro
que este factor no es el que origina los
problemas de los ecuatorianos debemos
pensar en el bien común y la paz
ciudadana los indígenas también piden el
control de los precios de los productos
agrícolas y un mayor presupuesto para la
educación para ellos el reciente anuncio
no es suficiente
hasta conseguir nuestros derechos
ciertas
tenemos para por lo menos
la verdad es que tenemos
el cierre de las vías y la escasez han
provocado también algunas
manifestaciones contra los bloqueos que
iniciaron el pasado 13 de junio
entretanto los legisladores discuten una
solicitud de la oposición para destituir
al presidente lazo aunque se requiere el
voto de al menos 92 de los 137
legisladores una cifra difícil de
alcanzar tomando en cuenta que la
oposición cuenta con apenas 50 curules y
terminamos en la amazonía brasileña con
el festival boy bomba también conocido
como pari tings pues así se llama la
ciudad donde se realiza durante tres
días dos equipos compitieron con
carrozas y decoraciones para demostrar
cuál era el mejor
al relatar la leyenda local de un buey
resucitado y otras historias de la
amazonía el ganador se dio a conocer
este lunes en el último de los días del
festival
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
france24
[Música]